ladies and gentlemen
flacco
what's up [ __ ]
you guys alright thank you for coming
out to felipe's podcast give it up for
yourselves coming out on wednesday night
[ __ ] pasadena eyes house
yeah you know why they call this place
the ice house
because they used to sell ice here
i'm [ __ ] serious they did that's why
it's called the iso sticks
look it up and then like maytag started
making freezers
and then people were like hey we don't
need you ice house [ __ ] you
and people kept coming to work like what
do we do now no one's buying ice
and the boss was like i don't know man
why don't you go up there and start
telling jokes
i'm [ __ ] bored
and someone walked in i was like hey man
this shit's pretty funny can i stay and
watch
we're like yeah pay 10 bucks
buy two drinks
we have plenty of ice
that's the story of the ice house
[ __ ]
what's up everyone my name is flacco
martinez born and raised in east l.a
chick you go to montebello maha
cause that's the ghetto what's small in
the [ __ ] world
it is have you been there they have a
[ __ ] hospital in the parking lot
what the [ __ ] is that for in case you
get stabbed they just throw you behind
jesse panties they're like
are the hots are gonna stick chicks rick
at nikolas at night
i'm sorry sam's off bro
you guys know that [ __ ] like money a
couple all right
i i live like in el serino if you don't
know where that's at you just take the
710 to hit the recycling center
it's right there it's a tough
neighborhood i'll hear stuff like hey
you're skinny we're gonna call you
flacco
i'd be like come everyone grandma you
got custody
that's what happens there mexican
families they just give you gangster
names
but like you're skinny so you're flacco
they come at that stranger
because never met that food
i got my grandpa chino because he can't
drive no more
my cousin widow has good credit
my uncle puppet he don't talk much
because his wife talks for him
who's a [ __ ] dude my cousin spider has
hairy legs
hey she don't like the shaver right
i have a niece with car negrita not
because she's dark but because she
steals
don't say all right [ __ ] that black
people mess with mexicans all the time
remember ocho cinco what the [ __ ] was
that about
that's [ __ ] up because i thought he
was mexican now he took off his helmet i
was like
vatos black that's [ __ ] up we don't do
that to black people
you don't see mexican soccer players
just changed their names to black
numbers
like deuces or pity
fo-fo sino
dubs one time
section eight you know what i'm saying
[ __ ] up dude
hey i can make these jokes all right
because the only women that like skinny
guys are big black women
because they like to floss
it's true like other women want a big
guy they're like i want someone that's
going to fight from him like [ __ ] caller
rage parker
i was with the bigger girl man that [ __ ]
wasn't fun she was talking about i like
it rough throwing me on the bed i was
like [ __ ] that you better jump
i'm gonna throw my back out cause you
wanna fly
i used to have an asian girlfriend but
didn't work out because we're too
different
i'd be like hey let's play checkers i
should bust all the marbles right
[ __ ]
and she had all these rules she's like
my people don't wear shoes while we're
indoors i'm like that's cool cause my
people don't wear condoms while we're in
bed
i get it baby it's all about comfort
she was kinky too because i would be in
bed and she'd be like i like when you
tease me i'm like all right you smell
like rice you drop that [ __ ]
she got mad and hit me with the nunchuck
i was like what the [ __ ] i thought we're
role-playing
i'm the bully you're the school girl
all these white people in here it's
[ __ ] scary as [ __ ]
at least we have alibis [ __ ] it
[ __ ] goes down just asking what happened
like i was here right white guy but
white people sucked dude you guys call
the cops for no reason man
it's not even your car
[ __ ] neighborhood watch what the [ __ ]
dude
mexicans won't do that [ __ ] if we see
someone break into a car
we'll be like hey someone's coming
give me an ipod [ __ ] white dude start
yelling out fancy words for stop
like hulk cease
desist what the [ __ ] is citizen's arrest
that's [ __ ] you can't arrest me if
you're not a cop
you can't just give yourself a job
can't do that [ __ ] anywhere else if i'm
at the laker game
the ball goes out of bounds i can't just
save it and pass it to kobe
but like citizens assist [ __ ]
[ __ ] i'm [ __ ] around white people
all right i'm cool with you guys
when i was a little kid i would only
play cops and robbers with my white
friends
because on my mexican friends i'd be
like
like they had oozies but white kids
can't roll their r's
baby
i'll be like what the [ __ ] is that dude
something's wrong you're gone bro
we couldn't play with black kids because
they had real guns and they would really
rob us
asian kids just throw a rock stay back
ninja star like hey [ __ ]
all right i'm gonna get out of here
before i go i'll let you guys know i'm
doing comedy i'm doing comedy because i
want to make money so i can adopt kids
from different races
that's my dream right i'd be like angela
jolie like a dude
like i'm adopted a black kid and a
mexican kid
a white kid and an asian kid because i
believe
raising them together is going to be
beautiful because one day
my black son my mexican son they're
gonna come up to me and they'll be like
dad
we're failing math i'll be there that's
cool kids
that's why we have china's son
i'm just saying because one day china
signed he'll come out to me he'll be
like that
he's got my ass kicked and these kids
just stole my bike
like china's son is [ __ ] up
but dry those eyes cause black son
maxi sun are gonna find those guys
kick their ass and steal your bike back
go on now get out of here white sun go
with them these guys gonna need alibi
all right shaw my name is flacco
martinez thank you enjoy the podcast you
guys have been great
what's up fool
welcome to the first ever live what's up
full podcast
and now your host felipe esparza
what's up food
what's up fool
oh man some of you guys what's up fool
it's the first ever
live podcast i hope you know there's a
podcast show yeah man
what's up fool and of course a big yeah
man for renting a tourist
man we're unplugged
oh man your thing on no it's not on i
don't [ __ ] take this one there
[ __ ] it
first of all big hand for flacco later
than just let him hear it
oh man let him hear it man i'm so glad
i'm so glad he made him mad because man
he just had a diabetic attack last night
you know
scary huh he's the kind of guy you bring
to your mom's house
he likes candy
i like to say left on the inside that's
where it counts
you're looking at her mama i thought it
was gonna be on a different type of
stuff but we're here man we're here man
how you doing sir man you're here [ __ ]
[ __ ] you're here man how you doing bro
what's up dog
from your parents or what oh my god yeah
all right
date nighty
like a mountain climber all right man
gotta get to the club yeah man what's up
fool what's up everybody what's up
first of all who listened to the podcast
all right man thank you man who doesn't
know what's going on
oh you're in for a [ __ ] surprise man
you're going to be like those broke
people that get something for free
and then feel it they got ripped off
oh bro when we got through they made us
buy drinks
what else did they make you do in the
club
oh what the hell already
yeah no i thought he left him
first of all thank you very much man you
know it's our first ever live podcast
normally we're in a studio and [ __ ] you
know hovered over you know
looking down like this now look we have
a live audience man we're like parking
we got rodrigo man i'm breathing over
the microphone right now and i did like
a
like a porn star
a porn star doing a solo
see myself filming a porno but like a
fat cameraman a background
hey can i touch your tool or whatever
don't be stingy hey
so what's someone's doing over here man
healing dog looking like a mexican ninja
over here and [ __ ]
i'm ready to sleep
having trouble breathing nothing just
chilling dog reminiscing about how lazy
i used to be at work dog
oh man just fall asleep like a city
worker dog
you know we went i was in pittsburgh
pennsylvania last week pittsburgh
pennsylvania
yeah man man there was a lot of people
who look like you sir over there
yeah they were looking at me like that
was a picture
and then at the end of the show they
told me you were hilarious man we were
there
before i changed it to the hotel the
hotel manager told me your room smelled
like weed
i said sword i haven't even checked in
yet man
you must have been a time traveler right
that guy just farted man so
give me ten dollars yeah so
with that man who's here from where you
from sir
that's okay that's pretty close it's
pretty close
thank you very much for showing up to
the what's up full podcast
it's gonna be live i hope you know all
people don't recognize your voice from a
crime or something
yeah that sounds like him man
you look for richard ramirez's son right
here people right here
yeah you got to know man but he raped a
girl in glendale and that's it
he's back imagine man always imagine man
what if like
you're like the son of a [ __ ] serial
rapist
and what do you do when you meet your
when you guys meet each other in a group
oh my oh [ __ ] he raped my mom too
you got to keep that legacy going i know
right i
feel like weird i don't know man [ __ ] it
let's talk about let's talk about
something funny man
we're losing the crowd they're still
here this is the part of the park that
we [ __ ] cut out for you guys
so you wouldn't think what the [ __ ] is
[ __ ]
right now perverse but nothing wrong
wrong with that man yeah
sir what's up man that joke bothered you
too high bothered me too
man that joke hurts all right what's up
big dog having a good time bro
hell yeah who drove him from real far
away man
the farthest where you got from over
there
damn that's far man welcome and get a
postcard dude
see that [ __ ] 14 with rough homegirl
right there
and you over there pastor damn man
messentina arizona she lives upstairs eh
wow so palmdale's the farthest anybody
drove from fallen
palmdale savannah
savannah georgia yeah but you didn't
[ __ ] fly out for the shogun
vacation to win a free prize
savannah georgia wilderness is true have
you heard of the podcast or you want a
free gift
oh look you're here you're here with
your white guy right here what are you
doing bro out there
welcome to california welcome man
so what brings you here from savannah
georgia
family you have family here in pasadena
you know a lot of mexicans
what who's your gardener
i'm sorry you're the that would be me if
i married a white girl who's your
gardener
who's your significant other
homeowner over there how happy you're
here look at her
i guess you made it
this is all have to borrow your mom's
car
damn soldier over there man
[ __ ] you ever do that man you bought
your mom's car then you crash it
and then you're laying in bed with blood
she works the magic in the back
you're breathing too hard you're too
close to the microphone
well sorry chilling or what rats oh
rats yeah dog right here in pasadena by
the way what's going on bro what's the
next over here brother
japan dog shout out to our homeboy in
japan oh shout out to frank rivas
he's one of our listeners in japan and
he translates our show in japanese
so you are here
people are listening to this i don't get
the impress i don't get we don't get the
impression on [ __ ] the radio we don't
get anything
you know funny man sometimes we try to
tell people about the podcast you know
they don't know what the [ __ ] i'm
talking about so what does that mean a
podcast no bro you want a radio
okay it's called a what's a full radio
show then they find it okay we're gonna
move on people [ __ ] it i'm dying here
i hate when a jojo doesn't work when a
joke when a joke doesn't work it feels
like you're watching a stripper
then she falls all right
when's this [ __ ] gonna get up
who hired this man sir right here right
i'm never coming here again at noon
[ __ ] nikolasi there's only one pole
man we got a shout out to another shot
and give a shout out bro
shout out to joey diaz who wanted to be
here right [ __ ] the way to be here
but
bro i'm sorry i'm doing a podcast of my
own leave me alone
exactly what he told us so yeah so uh he
wanted to be here but he's doing a
podcast of zono they're not north
hollywood so shout out to joey coco diaz
everybody
and look out for him on the church of
what's happening now
he's over there doing this thing man
he's going to be on a new game like
grand theft auto
he's going to be one of the bad guys
he's going to be in green and [ __ ] he's
having to run anything
snatching wallets and [ __ ] yes what else
we got shout out to nabil resa
you know who you are bro you support all
things comedy where you at over here we
[ __ ] dark we can't see you wait
we're gonna get you a hat too dawg
you're here
he's not here to [ __ ] you there you go
again savannah
and then alan to vegan foodshare alan
from veganfoodshare you here bro
what's up over there bro you got you a
hat too congrats dog who just reached
100 000 followers on instagram
let him hear
filipino married to a mexican [ __ ]
mexican girl they eat a lot of putto
yeah rice or maize vegan and phil and
she's vegan man
i taught people i'm vegan they don't
believe me man
who youthful what the [ __ ] you eat bro
craps
yeah so if you want to learn about vegan
food follow vegan food share man
and therefore give you like the places
where you can get crazy sir you want to
eat healthy you know
cholesterol and [ __ ] whatever your hands
you have ronias you know
sarah beyond whatever you got it
hey mexican we don't go to a doctor just
who are dying huh
[ __ ] what happened to your arm it's
purple but it's still moving there
put it back in my pocket eh just wrap it
with duct tape dog
you're a tin man now you know how we do
it dog
yeah man so thank you very much man for
the watch so full podcast and um
a shout out to all things comedy all
things comedy bro bring my glasses bro
you do it
you don't have your glasses dick no no
no no i could have sworn i let him right
here
but [ __ ] just look at rumors too not
bright enough for me all right it's a
trip dude like you can't see [ __ ] up
here but it's all good we're going to
keep moving
all right what are we moving here no no
you got it all right so all things
comedy
for having the what's up full podcast on
their network and all the proceeds from
the doors charge tonight or going to the
all things comedy network that was
started by alex monreal and bill burr so
please a shout out to all things comedy
network
getting on the podcast worldwide
and i was um thank you about vegan food
share you made be
your man crush when monday one time
he's red hot no me i crush [ __ ]
they're out of breath get off me
help real quick we're going to hook you
guys up uh we're going to mention the
upcoming tour dates you ready though
yeah bro april 9th to the 12th i'll be
in orlando improv in florida tell your
friends man
i look crazy with glasses huh
we're about to have an esoteric
conversation
and funny how [ __ ] glasses could just
make me look into an instant perverted
i'm afraid to talk to women so just look
at them
so they get scared now
oh man okay april 9 through the 12th
i'll be at orlando improv
orlando florida april 16 to the 18th
richland
anybody know anybody in richland
washington florida and jokers by the
tri-state
yakama and all that [ __ ] tell your
mexican friends to go man yeah man
we need people that's a ghetto ass club
by the way bro
that's the only club that has a chuck e
cheese a little [ __ ] place to play
blackjack
a dance club and a comedy club and a
daycare bro
well you should deal with chuck e cheese
jokers
and how about the atlanta punchline dog
oh look at that
atlanta punchline closed right next door
to atlanta punch line
they have a 24-hour day here 24 hours
people
lit [ __ ]
for real remember how it's tough it is
sometimes guys you meet a girl in here
at qc's
quiet canyon or something whether you're
old school at the hob
and she tells you off but i have my baby
[ __ ]
i got this app for a 24 hour daycare
[ __ ] they got similar
12 flavors eh and they're [ __ ] they
got alcohol for that tooth bro
funny huh some mexican ladies like we
don't we don't do it man but my mom
my grandmother she will put her finger
tequila and then put it on my mouth
yeah man because my tooth will hurting
man
and then i have to breastfeed with
tequila in my mouth
that's why like harry says drunk
may 1st and 2nd if you're in las vegas
to watch the manny pacquiao fight
we won't be there to watch the fight
because we're gonna [ __ ] take it
we're very looking for the room
we're gonna do a show may 1st and second
live stand-up comedy show
not live podcast like we are right now
with a table i know you're thinking what
the [ __ ] is the table there's a buffet
going on
yeah that'll be in las vegas that triple
b backstage bar in billiards
also just announced july 9
through the 11th i'll be performing here
at the ice house
stand-up shots july 9th through the 11th
people
live comedy show me and rodrigo some
other fools that i miss something
the miami one miami i feel like my
father
the further you put the [ __ ] bill the
cheaper they get him
making me nervous bro
this show's gonna suck man for people
who aren't here
[ __ ] it what's the dynasty i don't get
it i don't get it
show me your face
all right what's going on rodrigo will
be here
april 11 by himself next door at
the ice house stage two stage two he'll
be here with
mondo casillo and pops gracie and a
special guest
jay london yes thank you so he'll be
here uh
only ten dollars most of the money for
that show
will go for rodrigo or drugs and alcohol
but the money will stay in the community
only going to dab reviews trying to get
back to law school people
but uh in your miami florida day the
april 23rd through the 25th
who's here man what
oh no one more day for you dick the um
the april 23rd to the 25th miami florida
at the home field comedy and sports bar
ladies and gentlemen
this shouldn't even work either
i'm new to her glasses man like greasy
ass face
i started feeling hot too dog [ __ ]
glasses look like somebody [ __ ] threw
a chicken wing out of me
[ __ ] i said warsaw and [ __ ]
i always had a i was american in
elementary school i was like that dark
little [ __ ] man in elementary school
with a greasy ass face man ready for
actually like when i jump out of the car
the oil light will go on
[ __ ] today's florida as they call me
oh he got the joke oh ladies and
gentlemen tony bennett is the gentleman
tony bennett a round of applause for
tony bennett everybody let him here
i left my heart and lap went there
i'm just sorry sir we're just trying to
you know we're trying to get the show
flowing
that's not your dad right guy the beard
puts me in the headlights
here right like walked into a trapping
like what's going on
i'm waiting for a comedy show this fat
guy who looks like lost keep talking
he won't shut up man i'm not lost i'm
beast
you can see now all right oh who saw
who listened to our first ever podcast
the first episode the first episode
with juan garcia anybody listening to
that
you guys know the story juan garcia no
then you [ __ ] bro
catch up what's up full podcast
soundcloud that's the little
nina hey what's up well anyways
what's up juan garcia was a guy that was
on our show and um
he was our first guest on our comedy
show and he was a guy that i kidnapped
when i used to get really like really
[ __ ] [ __ ] poked out and [ __ ] like
to be a better
you know how it is man when you're when
you're coked out man you know how it is
having fun dawg you know where they're
trying to find moonshine you know
[ __ ] said moonshine you want to go
fox hunting there's nobody around
well you know how it is song for jesse
you know anyway so
enough enough
we're gonna give you a prize [ __ ] [ __ ]
this give him a hat he looks like a man
that wears hats no we'll get you
we got you big dog anyway this guy
ran when i you know when i used to be
all [ __ ] crazy
i used to i didn't have a car i didn't
have a [ __ ] car
so i would look for somebody with a car
that was short and desperate to be a
comedian
and i saw this guy named juan garcia
right and that foot took me in a coke
mission for three days man
that fool was in his mom's car huh yeah
it was like his mouth bad
she caught the bus to work bro
anyway so a lot of people asked they
wanted to see juan garcia here tonight
but that fools didn't want to be here he
he he rather
he rather instead of being here with us
a live
comedy show you know something really
big where people are going to remember
him and go oh [ __ ]
you're that [ __ ] i never thought you
know that fool that [ __ ]
that was down bro that fool when it was
that fool
he went nah man i can't do the podcast
because i have to do a show for
25 bucks what a fool right
in ontario we're gonna play our april
fool's joke on here man everybody
follow him right now on [ __ ]
instagram man
if you have a [ __ ] phone follow him
on instagram right now
at truly comedy comedy is bro i thought
right i thought you were gonna be there
bro on twitter and twitter too
on twitter trulycomedy84 so you have
twitter right now man a
good opportunity and tweet this
[ __ ] and tell them bro
and follow him i want his phone to blow
up with follows right now
and then at the end of the show we're
all going to unfollow that [ __ ]
[ __ ]
so right here man everybody if you have
a [ __ ] phone follow this [ __ ]
right now
he's a good hopefully we'll get him back
again
anyway so this fool right here everybody
follow your hey bro
are you are you going to be there i came
here to see you
you know and then at the end of the show
we'll unfollow this [ __ ] right
what the [ __ ]
that'll be his april fools so everybody
follow this [ __ ] anyways man
who who's a good baller who plays
basketball here by applause if you play
good ball you're a good baller
oh [ __ ] the mic crowley i have the most
unshaped fans hey
okay bro this [ __ ] right here
plays basketball at venice beach
and you can play this [ __ ] for
ten dollars
every saturday morning looking for him
man right here man if i hear anything
right here
looking like [ __ ] tight and albino
tyson and [ __ ]
looking like [ __ ] white chicks the
movie
[ __ ] chicken little alrighty anyway
that's our good friend juan garcia
there you go bro your phone's blowing is
the phone blowing up
all right trevor okay
happy as [ __ ]
he's been working
times are hard for a pen [ __ ] my puppy
has more followers
i follow one of the kardashians man
that [ __ ] gets 868 lights farting bro
what a [ __ ] track i'm one of them too
though but still
i feel bad for people man like some
people like juan garcia man
who puts up photos like this to be funny
three hours go by no likes
i like it but i've dropped the phone and
[ __ ] alright
okay we have a trivia question right
here for a free prize
in episode one
you have to raise your hand all right
don't be all shouting out all crazy
it's part of the podcast little tweet
it's fun [ __ ] it yeah man
raise your hand in episode one at the
crazy hollywood party
what could you earn by doing chores and
helping around the house
where where lisa
i'm not doing this i'm staying out of
this
i can't see [ __ ] i only see you i'm
right here around barney miller
whoa lisa who oh hey oh [ __ ] we're here
oh right here dum de luis over there
is the drummer from social distortion
[ __ ] mexican brutus eh
hey you asked for it dog
doggy point you got
oh [ __ ] you win a poster bro
and a half bro and dougie points where's
this bar at by the way
oh i don't have my phone dick all righty
we're gonna move on sorry people
doggy points we'll plug it on the um
dougie points dougie points so what
happened man what happened at the
hollywood party i was there at the
hollywood party
it was like a hollywood party
people say oh bro we had a party at the
hills what hills
whittier there's no hills over there
it was lake lake now
so at this party at this episode one
real quick at this party there was a guy
named doug
uh whatever anyway at this point it was
a crazy party when that [ __ ] party
went from 11
from 2 in the morning to 11 00 in the
morning man
it was crazy man it was a crazy ass
party
anyway so zombie party but you know in
order to get invited back to this crazy
party you have to do things like
pick up an ass tray and throw in a trash
can and then the guy who owned the house
will give you doggy points
and he'll look at you and shoot in his
bathroom hey bro you got seven doggie
points
in my room the whole night i was [ __ ]
tweaking man i think i broke the record
everyone's mopping sweeping bro
replacing light bulbs
because i think you broke the dirty
point wreckers dog
yeah so that's doggy points we're trying
to get him to come to the show man but
you know man
he don't know we made it he was having a
hollywood party he's having a halloween
party right now man
but this house was crazy man like you've
been to ditching parties but this was a
pitching party man
i mean like you know how sometimes you
go to our palace party and you get
[ __ ] up
and you see fat ass trolls peeing on
your wall and [ __ ]
or the [ __ ] chick trying to pee and
[ __ ] on your lawn
they had bathroom stalls installed on
the back of the house
so if you're peeing on the house there's
like a bathroom stall you flush it
the [ __ ] was elaborate yeah i cleaned it
so i got dougie
dougie point sir
all right people are getting ready to
get this [ __ ] started
oh [ __ ] oh what
also a big handful of girl the guy who
introduced me little miklo ladies and
gentlemen
that's isaac hayes
yes
i will respond but they can't hear you
on a podcast so
i'll be talking to the wind
be a gentleman up here also we're
actually in a lot we're even though
we're doing a live comedy live podcast
we're here at a live show at a comedy
club
tip your waist especially him over there
man
yeah man you might have seen him like in
porno movies on
[ __ ] on bang bros
brazers all the guys know him alright
world famous yeah man he's trying to buy
wheat off me he's ten dollars short man
do it for the rasa one more time
oh man trivia okay trivia question okay
back to the [ __ ] uh my glasses
where right here oh
i don't need that for this
where is it
how many asian guests have we had so far
and what are their names
who say one right here what's that widow
one who was his name
that's good that's a good way he got us
in huh we thought you were dead you're
alive
that's even better with me no i can't
see [ __ ] i just see the light right here
man
richard chain richard chad yes
richard chan man we had him here
also we had a rafael cardenas right here
from east l.a right here photographer
if you're wondering he's not sneaking
through purses he's taking pictures this
guy's the official guy that used to ch
he used to get chased by sevoya and
performing
man that light is like right on top of
me man
oh what okay what we're introducing
in uh in uh richard uh okay please and
gentlemen welcome richard shannon
and sherms back on the show what up
richard
all right bro have a seat richard shan
right here
right here [ __ ] richard chandler
hello that one over there
no hello hello hello okay rodrigo
hello okay man find something you like
to hold
hey so what's up food is that anything
on
uh hello [ __ ] it yes hey rodrigo sorry
bro
all right
all righty we're here what's up boy you
wanna laugh just come up
what's up everybody we have richard chan
right here man
hey everybody
hey arrival
all right hello
hello hello hello there
anybody in there
hello yeah man all right man so just
just share man [ __ ] it
just share it okay hello
all righty i like yours better now
hey where's my bike man what bike i'm
flaco sun man china
tell everybody who you are man but first
of all richard chan
speaks better spanish than me
he's half mexican his name is chingao
that's short for chingada mother right
well we're here
so what's up man first of all you guys
don't know man
um sure he was on the show and he was on
the show and we talked about um
oh central kidnapping central oh yeah
who heard that story about when when
when i kidnapped we weren't in austin
anybody
heard the story
now you guys are missing out man show up
to the wrong [ __ ] show
now anyways so tell them you have to
know shirts man this guy
grew up in catalina island so his family
not only snuck into america got here
they [ __ ]
they just swim over there now
[ __ ] it just a little further all right
how did mexicans land in catalina
i don't know the funny thing is though
we're just here for the tour but we're
going to stay
a three hour tour hey the funny thing is
most of them
see a lot of jobs
and most of them are from the same
little small town in jalisco
yeah it was crazy hey um christmas break
uh go down and go visit my mom's family
you go to the microphone bro don't be
shy i don't spit it
what the [ __ ] man it got you dog
nah but uh christmas break we used to go
down there and visit my grandparents and
we'd run into
carolina no in mexico but
for [ __ ] mexico another island
but half of catalina was there went to
the mainland
this is the wrong island so what
happened bro
um nothing just [ __ ] the same people
the end all right
no bro carolina bro all right catalina
how did you grow up with carolina oh
that [ __ ] is small
i was very you can't even break up with
somebody
you break up with him you see him every
day
swap backs all right cool so what's it
like what was it like growing up in
catalina i was pretty cool man i mean
everything was really small there so
like you said
that's what she said it's a big ass
island all right
but like you said you couldn't go out
with anyone there because as soon as you
did
your best friend was dating them you
know so
kind of [ __ ] up one big happy family
dog oh hey [ __ ] it dude it's cool
so you used to go fishing over there
what do people do how did your dad
survive what do you do [ __ ] swim to
long beach to work and then come back
he's still on his way back right now all
right
no uh it's so small town so just you
know
yeah everyone everyone over there
cruises on golf carts
and it's a little small island
[ __ ] driveway on golf carts
throw a golf ball bam who was it
condo five
hey tell them about the golf cart with
the rims and the flame paint job
say what hey this guy knows more about
catalina than i do
no but everyone there they had golf
carts and everyone used to hook them up
so you'd have golf carts there was a
sound system
what are you laughing at man
that's how you do it has spinners on
them has stereos
say what that's what i call balling over
there hell yeah
play my golf cart carolina island
there's a lot of buffalos right oh
there's a lot of buffalos man
god damn man oh yeah they took them
there for a movie and they
left them there they never brought them
back the funny how mexicans got their
house [ __ ] one movie you know what it
is
and we're gonna take the buffalo back
but we changed our mind you know what
i like playing this part
i thought mexicans do my sneak into
movies and [ __ ] oh yeah
ease up in that [ __ ] so what's
up man what happened
we had richard chen on the show one time
and he used to live in tijuana mexico
yeah he used to teach spanish and
english over there and his well
yeah man i lived here for ten years for
ten years yeah and then he had a coffee
shop in mexico
and then they tried to tax him and he
[ __ ] [ __ ] that he left
what happened tell us the story bro your
wife putting a hit on you bro
oh man you know that story yeah
he's supposed to be dead
exactly right we'll call the a team
well my my ex she's now my ex yeah also
from jalisco
don't trust a lady from jalisco right
they don't know how to cook that's a lie
right i'm gonna love you too
i'm gonna cook for you [ __ ] that that's
a lie
all right i'm going with a girl from
hallease one time she opened her legs
more like cheese
and then it falls apart when you touch
it you know
we're going to lose our contract with
disney bro
flatline hey
so what's up man what happened when we
had him on the show and he told us this
crazy story man because um he's a big
hulk hogan fan right
what's up hell yeah hulk hogan he's
alive
and and here when he him and his friends
hulk hogan used to have a hotline
that you could dial and you'll speak to
a fake hulk hogan
and hoco could tell you hey brother if
you're able to drop the legs drop press
nine
and this will wrestle pressing numbers
that bill came out to a thousand dollars
and i was telling her i couldn't just
call 976 kids bro
so help her real quick bro tell us the
story bro real quick oh yeah we used to
call
we're big hulk hogan fans so uh we found
hulk hogan had a hotline uh
1 800 949 hulk but uh
it was hot you guys called it two or
what
cool i'm not the only one but but yeah
we used to call hulk hogan but you could
never really beat him
so ah
all right what's up uh listen up brother
hokogean here and you fought him so like
he said
press one if you want a leg drop know
all right press one
press two if you want me to take off
your shirt all right cool press two
this one was like damn listen which one
do i push for him to put it back on
but yeah we we'd always play but [ __ ] we
never won
it's a psych yeah [ __ ] one long
summer man
my buddy we used to call for my buddy's
phone so uh
his mom got the bill
but like you said we never want one hell
of an expensive bill
how much was it i don't know
you might win wrestlemania wild on your
way
now you got to wrestle my ass already
oh real quick this one told me a funny
ass story he was in a uh a strip club
and said aloha huh you were just
chilling in [ __ ] and the chicks
well thank you very much man thank you
thank you guys richard shannon
thank you you guys are [ __ ] awesome
bro thank you thank you man
yeah go to catalina and look for sherms
over there man
the [ __ ] rv [ __ ] golf carting
a little leg breaker and [ __ ]
it went from a good time how you guys
doing we're so full
all righty ladies and gentlemen a
surprise guest
don't forget man follow this
[ __ ] man
right here sippy yeen son right here
right here man
all right man from not even we have a
special guest here man i've been on the
radio show
who is this who listens to 95.5
kilowatts
this guy man big hand for frasier smith
mr show business
show business people hey buddy how you
doing buddy
yeah oh yeah what's up bro have a seat
sir
what's up fool what's up fool
i got a new saying i got a new saying uh
what's crack and [ __ ]
does that [ __ ] work yeah all right
now i got to get a podcast come on let's
do this [ __ ] come on
so what's up full freezer smith saying
hi to everybody here hey everybody
how you doing good to see you guys
man growing up here in los angeles i
used to grew up listening to 95.5
kilowatts
you know what some other heavy metal
girl used to have the eyebrows
yeah you're still rocking that deal
shirt come on you got to rock deal
yeah it's like a rainbow in the dark so
when do you show on
my show is on uh i'm i i broadcast out
of catalina island
you got good radio waves over there you
know yeah i gotta swim to long beach
and then we do the show sunday night ten
till two
sunday night prime time prime time
i'm rolling kilo g guys
whatever the hell that means
that was wild that guys i think catalina
huh that guy is wild
yeah i was like i'm the guy who brought
the buffalo there i uh
and the messies and the blacks all right
yeah that's it
i'm a buffalo soldier
so we got you we got you this man right
here we'll show the other way
what did he do he killed away from our
leader california our leader
i used to date her hey sir where you
from sir
thank you sir thank you sir you're here
man yeah man
uh so i had this had a hollywood party
yesterday
uh and i was cleaning [ __ ] up
i had the uh with the straw
well you got to clean [ __ ] up i mean
come on
blurred lines talk about blurred lines
banks so you're
oh my favorite comedian uh probably uh
oh man johnny carson
oh right my favorite yeah he's weird
crazy
that was my impression no but i was at a
party where he was
he told me to get the [ __ ] out
well i was there he cut you off and hey
buddy yeah
then he had to clean some [ __ ] up in his
house i got some johnny carson points
he's been listening he's been listening
yeah johnny carson points that's it [ __ ]
my favorite joke you say man is the one
you say can i say it
yeah is the one you say that um dr dr
kevorkian has a waiting room now
the nurse comes out and he sells she
says um the doctor will kill you enough
smither
that is my your first job i love you
you did now you got to clean up [ __ ]
sorry sorry maybe you're nervous sir he
does have a
he does make you nervous he doesn't
matter that's my dad by the way
i'm sorry mr freezer good to see you
pops
yeah buddy what's up fool
what's up food yeah
so every sunday is your show on kos
every sunday night ten tell two i really
appreciate both of you listening
no if you if you get a chance please
listen i really appreciate it you were
on there the other day
you were fantastic we our ratings went
down but uh
he's on everybody that's gonna happen
that'll happen
bang bang yeah but i'm big on catalina
the buffalo are listening and uh
everybody
what happened what happened i was
looking at that big troll over there
let me handle something real quick it's
a big ass tournament nothing
wow nothing like a big choker out of a
van and [ __ ]
ass hand and a little pistol so your
game so
you're from where sherman knows no no
represent 818 [ __ ]
so you're a laker fan i am a laker fan
yeah
yeah yeah i'm a lego fan
although they are having a rough year
last week last week they lost to the
sparks
and i i liked it better when the i like
better when the clippers used to suck
yeah right at least you get a ticket
right
right you called the box office what
times the game starts they're like
i don't know what time can i get here
we're in the thick get there early to
let you play center
and you know you're in trouble when you
leave early to beat traffic and there's
a player sitting next to you at the
light
folks come on jokes these are the jokes
people
oh my god yeah yeah
yeah fool what's so cool what's up
burbank
i represent look at her like matt
locking [ __ ] yeah okay
that's all she wrote that's it
so we performing that next uh next i
will be
uh depends on what's on this card
i'm gonna pick up some [ __ ] at ralph's
apparently
you know what we know what's scary man
when you go to ralph's right and you see
that i'm not
the same person panhandling all the time
the same person
but sometimes they don't they don't ask
for money they tell you can you just buy
me something in there
and i mean they're all high and she
looking around
and then i forget what the [ __ ] i'm
there for and [ __ ]
and then later you see them they've
eaten all the samples
i love samples samples
membership over there
i'll sell you a fake card this is like
she got kicked out a couple times
wow i don't know membership man i have a
membership at food for less
food for letters you don't need
membership foreign
[ __ ] you can buy a [ __ ] milk and
kevin hart new movie
yeah it's a good combo
so what's up fool what's up pool all
right man
we're gonna bring another guest what's
up i gotta go i gotta get back to uh
catalina
i'm swimming back so wish me luck thank
you guys thank you fraser smith
supporters
come out everybody have a good time
all right brother check him out
yeah buddy that fool's funny huh
ain't that right buddy hilarious man i
like the quick one-landers man man
i don't have to think too hard you know
telling me buddy
like
what's up fool we're back okay just a
little minor block in my mind
trivia question people are you ready for
more trivia are you ready
which one of our guests former guests
had sex with kathy griffin
griffin he had he has sex with um the
doctor player alfredo griffin from back
in the face
eddie griffin you bro right here
fred stoller yes he got your name
everybody
i don't know what you win bro
rodrigo water you win fred stoner's
book we're gonna hook you up with fred
soller's brother you're wearing fresh
stoner's book right here let me see here
let me show everybody bro the book here
what's your name by the way
jerry you have a latina right there hey
i guess you made it
you have a white chick i have a white
chick here's a here the white chick
shake
crackers and [ __ ] bro
[ __ ] we go to mexican and white shakes
white chicks and mexicans crackers and
[ __ ] we go together like nascar and
nachos
so that's fresh told her man he wrote
this book and we're on our show
so ladies and gentlemen your next guest
friend stoller
freddie freddie staller
i'm from catalina
everybody's saying i know him from
somewhere
he's been on everybody like rain man and
every all that stuff people come on
and uh i blocked out kathy griffin that
we had sex so i wouldn't have won the
book
i blocked it out
it's it's gone from my memory i went to
a little
thing but do you know what kathy griffin
is
i heard the girl she sorry so what's up
full fred how you been man
i'm good i'm good who heard him on a
podcast by applause
hollywood dreamers series he was on our
podcast show
and he's been on seinfeld of course he
wrote for seinfeld who's seen them on
seinfeld
they don't like seinfeld everybody loves
raymond cousin gerard
how about handy manny
manny don't you have kids i'm the rusty
the monkey wrench
hi manny i'm scared
i learned my spanish trabahamas we
travel the bahamas
they don't you did either you don't have
kids or
no one so handy or you're a pedophile
you're uh i uh rodrigo
what's happening you know you keep
saying we should hang out
and i feel guilty cause if i because i
have bugs in my place
and weren't you an exterminator i'll
hook it up it will hook you up but don't
you feel you're being used
no all right give me like a little weed
gummy bear or something
yeah yeah yeah send me on my way i'll
hook you
what kind of bugs you have i
i just was on the thing and then i don't
read the comments with the doug thing
with the
i got stoned on a podcast what's that
show getting dug with high
well this show getting dug with high
with with doug benson and
we sit like this except there's a bong
everywhere
and during the podcast they keep giving
you more bongs
and towards the end you're like doing a
parking lot under the table like dudes
and people are going that guy was an
idiot but
you yeah but i was stoned so uh oh what
do you expect that i won't ever show you
spin round and round and i get mad at
people for being dizzy
all right bring the other guys back i
suck
see if i went first i think i was
killing because i have nothing to
compare this to
but i heard back there they were great
and
and these women are looking at me very
scared like that's that
that's that tinder guy we had a date
with who lied about his age
put another picture up and i was scared
and i
had my cousin the cop waiting but i
don't know what they're all talking
about
but don't go on tinder
so you're gonna start a podcast yes i'm
because of the success of this right now
i'm gonna do a podcast
actually i was gonna but now i changed
my mind
i i wanna yes i'm gonna do on all things
comedy
i'm gonna do one but it's gonna it's
gonna be unique it's gonna be different
it's it's gonna my hook is i'm not funny
and uh oh well i'm hallucinating the
sons of anarchy guy right
whoa
that that is you yeah all right i'm
getting goosebumps you know uh
so that show [ __ ] pisses me off you
british guys taking acting gigs from me
i could have been him or jax
he talks like hi hi he's this pretty guy
and he headbutts everyone it beats the
[ __ ] out of him
did you go in real life dude you
wouldn't be beating people up did you
tell him
he's a good guy but i don't believe he
could beat everyone up
dude i heard those guys really believe
but i i loved it i watched it
so good for you yeah yeah
and and at lunch did you did you sit
separately or everyone hung out together
okay it's not because they had racial
problems
okay no i love the show i know a guy
that was on it that's how i got into it
christopher reed
yeah that's the guy from kid and play
but
don't be funny how the guy from kittens
sounds yeah
with this flat top huh you know what i'm
talking about
he was there was a guy friend he was he
was one of the uh
i was going to say [ __ ] but uh
what the the trainees the the [ __ ]
no no what are they
prospects oh yeah all right hey prospect
yeah he was a big guy but uh all right
all right i got my money's worth hey
i like that guy all right yeah so what's
up friends told her man everybody know
man
you started stand-up comedy in new york
yeah i started in new york city
and um and then i got people asked me
what was my big break i go
uh tonight i have to
thank god i was in a dumb and dumber
and um get off the phone
get off the phone this guy oh [ __ ]
i don't want to google it anymore
so stuff like that brought me out here
to la and uh
i i actually opened for you we didn't
show them bria him and i
and we did uh reno reno
ontario right here barney rubble so
burbanky no i love working for felipe
he's you do
selfie after with everyone
are you gonna do it for tonight for
these guys we'll do it hell yeah we'll
be chilling for sure
i have a rule with selfies five bucks
that's how much i'm willing to pay
because i'm lonely yeah put your hand
around i'm old school i remember when
southfield used to be going under my
bedroom with a porno
don't look at me take my selfie
so how'd you
so i didn't where did you know me from
you knew me from young comedian
specialist
i saw you uh young comedian special you
know a long time ago
then i saw you on of course everybody
knows raymond's and
cousin bernard right i was unraveling my
little raymond
i was the cousin cousin bernard jarrod
jerome i don't know man
you don't know anything we could be
making this all up they don't know the
[ __ ] mexicans will say the wrong name
for years huh
bernardo no [ __ ] you brother saying
bernardo
gerard latinos always come up to me they
go
are you coming out and anything i
haven't seen you come out in anything
like i'm gay hey i'm on sons of anarchy
i
but right why do you say that not i mean
you but i don't know man
all right good stay here well stay here
man don't go nowhere man
all right ladies and gentlemen we have
another gift on the show man this guy
was on our show on the cholos
where are you when i was here wait where
are you give it up for birdman
people san jose's finest yeah
san jose's finest all right bro he
brought dabs oh [ __ ]
oh yeah extracts million extracts baby
they keep keep going
anyway man we were all in reno all three
one time man and we went we
partied we partied hard man they told us
hey
you gotta put a [ __ ] turn down the
heater
that [ __ ] is loud you know what's funny
man when i was in reno new year's eve
i said if you know what [ __ ] it was
birdman's birthday i'm gonna buy him a
present
so i went to his pawn store right
chris birdman man and i saw a raider
ring
silver sterling ring see it right there
you guys are taking off yeah
and i said you don't want to buy that
for birdman and then
the guy said how much is it for that
[ __ ] ring bro
150 fog bro you guys they're winning
this [ __ ]
for reals right i was flabbergasted at
that price
and i said come on bro it's [ __ ] guy
man he loves the raiders birdman you
know
and then he goes just keep [ __ ] he
goes all right guys give me 80.
then i said come on man i'll give you
60.
you're [ __ ] the raiders suck just
give me 40.
don't say this so they give you 50 now i
almost tucked myself into more money man
i bought it for 45 dollars and it's
right there ray it's like
here in good hands good hands
at 150 what the [ __ ]
reno is a depressing town it's reno man
you know what it was voted the most
depressing town
in america is that not cause i was there
no reno yeah
all right well we live there
we went to ede and it was like the worst
foods from cafeteria
enough for him and his wife oh yeah you
were taking your wife
we thought let's get out of here it's so
depressing so finally
his wife or was it someone was not
finishing
so you took our food and dumped it on
your plate and started eating from
scratch
and he thought it was like eating like
he was in prison with one arm right here
is [ __ ]
don't touch my [ __ ] bro it's weird like
when you hang out with people that been
locked up for a long time
oh you guys trying to eat all the food
like he wants to put into a conversation
i was just like [ __ ] it like birdman
like he was like blocked off
and he thought it was good food yeah man
[ __ ] you like that food from
christmas vacation you know don't get
cheap on me san quentin got better food
in that [ __ ] spot
yeah like so birdman like birdman one of
our friends from san jose we meet him
he's a comedian you know
he's like you know he you did time right
like 30 years
about 20 all together or something 20
right so it's weird to have a
conversation with him because sometimes
he wants to say something
and he throws like a long string with a
sock on it you know
hey i go fishing bro i go i got my way
of
his facebook things scare me
i still keester my phone you go [ __ ]
this [ __ ] i don't know what you're
talking about but i like it i don't know
i like everything he said we went to
starbucks to take us birdman
took the the mega bus over here from
[ __ ] san jose right yes sir
all the way down remind me that sam
queen right just shackle this
all these bunch of [ __ ] jay cats and
derelicts coke fans like what the [ __ ]
back home
yeah it's like san jose came with me
yeah man so man this looks like a scene
from get hard too
this man looking at birdman like how
come that guy from
jurassic park is doing what he's doing
here
welcome to jurassic park
he's got a new genre msnbc lockup comedy
yeah he does msnbc lockup comedy
tell them one of your jokes bro
you know look man you guys gotta
understand receiving oral sex while
you're incarcerated does not make you a
gay prisoner
it just makes you a happy camper
it's only gay if you come
i i he didn't he did it for cigarettes
and he didn't even
he didn't even smoke [ __ ] seriously top
ramens
you need a celly for that one dog
burbank can make you a cake with oreos
cookies and [ __ ]
a spread was there anyone skinny like me
in prison and jewish
yeah they were holding onto my belt loop
i see some good chemistry right here
i can see a sitcom right here right yeah
like instead you see right here locked
up right here right here [ __ ] is
he's wearing a state issue jacket that's
what the [ __ ] i was wondering about
sing things that's a susanville jacket
bro
jacket bro you get that in prison for
free i'm not gonna get shot
you what do you mean that kind of jacket
what are you doing
right now all right he's doing the [ __ ]
out of me
the thought of prison i have nightmares
i mean uh if you go there i go could i
are you allowed to volunteer for a
solitary confinement go this
could i go please please you wouldn't
want to be in this
[ __ ] don't ask me i don't know i'm sorry
the reason they call him birdman because
he walks around with a bird on his
shoulder like
some people have a chip on their
shoulder he has a bird on his shoulder
a real like pocket umbrella cockatoo i
got an umbrella cockatoo
cockatoo yes sir oh that that is
any coffee [ __ ] we're doing
i know i'm bombing when the guy in the
front row is doing better than me
he's killing doug
should be up here and i should be
sitting there with the uh over here you
look like a guy in like uh
to kill a mockingbird like in the jury
or something uh
with the thing or like the guy in his
bench
miracle on 34th street we got a lot of
you guys here you know what you're
saying
people trim your question all right
what was my girlfriend's rap name for me
in high school
when even though i didn't [ __ ] rap
what anybody
for real here's our story man what
happened what
kmc you got a damn girl over there
palmdale got it
yeah yeah got the trivia unlucky
anyway this was the story man you got it
mika
you're gonna win over there dressed in
black and white
over there next to beetlejuice
oh i don't know every time i see stripes
i say beetlejuice like
right here peel juice
beetlejuice pita juice still
a long beach also you know you should
have a pet
you should have a pen pal with [ __ ]
shrooms eh
yeah all right people have a good time
pay that bill pay i know the [ __ ]
check is falling down all right all
right
everyone had a good time all right okay
man so how's it going birdman
everything's going good bro everything's
going good life's sweet just out there
hitting their mics telling them jokes
getting high
staying high on my chameleon extracts
all right so when you're telling your
your podcast is
is it not things comedy french it will
be it will be we're we're saving up the
episodes
and you know the title yeah i'll talk
about it yeah i'll let everyone know
when it drops
see i got the lingo when it drops
i feel like andy kindler hey
well thank you man fred stoller and
birdman
birdman let him hear it everybody thank
you bro thank you very much
i should be in the movie man running
scared
or the odd couple of bono heights
what's up there savannah what's going on
over there over there
all right all right making bacon
alrighty
all right man our next guest
who heard of the the richard ramirez the
nice talker
well this guy's the man who caught that
[ __ ]
footsteps [ __ ] we're going to
tailgate this here
so what's everybody if you guys don't
know welcome to the show mr
gilchrist how are you doing how you
doing brother when we first did our show
man we didn't know like how
what kind of theme we're gonna have for
a podcast you know like everybody does
comedy
they do this they bring a bunch of
comedians they talk about jokes they
whine they complain
so we just figured you know we'll just
run into people from that i know from
the streets
growing up or interesting stories and
this man right here he was involved in
the
in the investigation of richard ramirez
and this guy
caught that [ __ ]
if it wasn't for him they would have
killed him
so how you been man i'm so are they
going to do that
richard ramirez movie with um with um
what's his name
what's his name james franco
i don't know about the movie business i
know we brought the rights of the book
uh lifetime channel is doing something
close lifetime channel is doing
something uh
they're supposed to start shooting in
may i believe
for television and james franco still
has the the other rights i understand
yeah i don't know you ain't contacting
my door you know he's not knocking me
and i ain't going to catalina looking
for him either
she was saying dog man the bounty hunter
getting there
yeah so you were one of our guests you
know a lot of people did this to our
podcast
you know and i think somebody emailed
they wanted you to speak for them did
they ever get kind of talk to you
yes yes i've spoken all over i've been
all over the u.s speaking about them and
i've just been
this guy investigated the oh sorry no no
go ahead go ahead
hey this is your gig brother
no so tell these people man who who who
you investigated your biggest case
well there is no bigger k you know
richard ramirez he was uh he was the
biggie he had everybody and
everybody in the county scared and then
he went to the vaudeville and the
various got him and took him down that
was him
sorry
man when they were looking for rich
ramirez ma'am everybody in the
neighborhood swear he saw here man
i swear bro i saw him at caddies
he was like qcs bro
i saw that for a pavilion
damn alpha beta she took an old school
big bite
she still has a shopping cart so what
happened you investigated him
well we investigated him he didn't die
in the paper i put my swing has a dress
in there see if he'd hit that but he
didn't
so uh he eventually got caught august
31st 1985 taking into custody
found guilty sentenced to death uh he's
still alive right oh he died
oh he died he died june 7th 2013 natural
causes he's dead
appeals over with guilty guilty
while natural cause people were saying
that honey died natural causes a tree
fell on him
he was hit by lightning so those are big
man what was it like like a lot of a lot
of us right here man we just watched the
news
we just lost a little [ __ ] and they're
looking for a [ __ ] serial killer
or we just close our windows and [ __ ] i
don't know my father man during the i
was a little like in junior high when
they were looking for the night stalker
and um this is what my father did man to
protect us
he didn't buy no gun all he did was
break the [ __ ] broom
and put the broken broom handle on the
window so it won't open if they try it
because that scares away that kukui
they ain't the gun sales go up during
ritual americans none sales went up
everything went up
your dad wasn't that far because i
remember putting up on my back gate
i put a shovel right there to hold it in
place and i'm going to come into my
place
it's funny how people from the
neighborhood sometimes they do weird
stuff like my neighbor will put aluminum
foil her windows man
because they keep the sun out then you
can cook tortillas on your window and
[ __ ]
so man you're a dodger fan i'm a big
time dodger
glad birdman left he's a [ __ ] giant
fan
so man you're a big time dodger fans and
they want you to be
well i started watching when they got
here to the coliseum 58.
damn you were there i was there selling
cokes
any coke will do
he looks like he had himself penis over
there understand everything
so man what do you think about so
anybody here what do you think about the
tailgating at dodger stadium how they're
trying to avoid it do you have a
tailgate
no no i never did tail anyway people
don't have no fool i'm gonna come back
you never tailgated the tailgate i've
tailgated it uh usually
right other functions usc but uh never
daughter stadium because
they would always make you throw your
[ __ ] away you know so i i'm not going to
throw nothing away
[ __ ] man we tailgate echo park now man
it got bad last year at the tailgate at
dodger stadium and
people hired bands
and somebody actually wrote a letter man
like yeah man it was so noisy
and there was a banda it was a quotation
on paisa style band
with tubas so it was like poker music
but with lyrics
am i lying pump
so you're gonna go to opening day uh no
i'm not gonna be at opening day i have
another uh
engagement that i had to do some
speaking at that day so i'm not gonna be
able to make it
but um i'm sure i'll go to many more so
since you caught an investigator the the
night stalker you've been asked to speak
for other police officers all over the
world i've spoken all over
all over the nation i've been out of the
country name has been submitted to go to
russia
it's cool so you go over there man you
teach the africans how to catch serial
killers
you go to the london yards
how is it there's some british bro right
here
live at scotland yard man please tell us
how to catch
jack the ripper
that's easy he's already dead eh thank
you
what happened sir it's a bloody man
it's a bloody mess thank you sir
so um
so you're an ex-sheriff i'm a former
sheriff retired game 38 years 26 working
murders
hard times so you can relate to um
birdman he's been involved in a lot of
police brutality
they'd be testing out batons on that
fool
he's been given a lot of flash type
flashlight therapy
flashlight therapy when you're locked up
and then the police officer hits you
with a black flashlight
in your elbows and your ankles so they
won't see the bruises
anyway that's just the urban legend
right sir
never heard of such a thing so so
you're also in a band still yeah i'm
still uh still playing
having fun just you know i i did it back
in the day uh
when i was when i was a kid playing the
little union big union armani legion
stadium
palladium you know don palace we did it
all and now we're starting to do it
again it's
making it come back and i'm blowing with
some good guys
it's good to have like someone on you
with a real story man like growing up
you went to vietnam and you started a
hospital in vietnam for the kids we
started an orphanage in vietnam
you do good things bro without anybody
telling them man
you like you man you're not one of those
guys that looks for prizes
or big posters no i didn't think that
they did you know
we're letting everybody know man you're
the man bro a man that speaks through
examples
whenever i get in trouble i know a
sheriff
you know it didn't start out like that
because i was 17 years old when the cops
took me home
and told my parents sign for him to get
off the street he's gonna end up dead or
in prison
so at 17 i did go into the service and
so that's what
that changed my life and now here i am
and being able to talk about a local
mexican kid you know
there is hope hell yeah that's what's up
brother
hell yeah man go to jail or go the army
dude
it's funny man they try to get me to
join the army man the cop the
marine went to my school he said i see a
leader in you shut the [ __ ] up me bro
i showed up late to school today
i'm in the wrong class
dick yeah man so thank you very much
thank you having fun like i'm having a
great
time all right barry your career google
him
hell yeah man i like gil carrillo man
hell yeah you need to come to all our
shows
for real when i would do like crazy-ass
bars like montebello bars
he will show up man and just be there
with his wife laughing man
you know he gave me his card every more
time i got in trouble man
i was telling the cop i know somebody
ran
who do you know
[ __ ] man so what's up so what's your
name by the way i don't wanna
ron thank you ron for being here burbank
yeah right there front row ron
what was your date with craigslist what
happened
she's she's in the back texting right
now
no sir all right people marquez you got
ready
are you ready more guests
you guys ready people
all right no setups no sit ups
all right ladies and gentlemen amanda
and pops
armando sexy [ __ ]
people and the son
yeah little brother how you doing pops
it's denim night
what's up pups what's up dog you got it
i together the oyster stuck right here
what's up how are you bro mondo
where are you what's up what's happening
chilling dog
what's who listens to our podcast with
armando kocio
yeah amanda cosio is somebody that i met
during comedy and him and i wish to tour
with gabriel glass yes
yeah back to the day but it was funny
huh
that's sexy [ __ ] yeah i used to tour
with the night stalker but uh
gil put a stop to that
big hat for gil carrillo man that was
good
god damn it let him hear it
so what's up pups not much full
all right puffs is on pops and armando's
son and um he does stand-up comedy too
and um i met him when i first started
doing comedy
what a long time ago man when i wasn't
really that funny and
we should go eat thai food together and
then strip bar right after
let me tell you about you have not lived
till you get a lap dance smiling like
chicken curry man
she's earning that money making birthday
with heartburn
she said give me a thumb tool what's up
pops
what's happening
put the microphone closer yeah he's
right there choking
so what's going on bro what's new what's
new nah
man just messing with people
over the phone every time
i answer the phone um could i help you
what's the matter are you drunk i tell
them
no man it's too early
yeah i'm back because they think i'm
drunk
they call him one guy goes hey bro
can't head in there yes
it looks like you're all dabbed out over
here dog yeah
and i'm let go right here answering the
on the other line other hand
mouthful it's just how i talk
i have a speech department and man you
should see them
their faces i can see it but i can hear
here it is the voice oh man i [ __ ] up
how did you became like that
did everybody know man to know you were
hit by what
oh [ __ ] ain't one like
it as you can see i'm about right
what happened i'm all right
no i didn't hear you say it as you can
see i'm all right
but now i got hit by a drunk driver
oh but don't worry now he's okay
see it's funny man it pops drives
yeah it drives like a special steering
wheel that looks like a
steering wheel that has a doorknob on it
and you go like this like a bus full
yeah right away to explain it yeah
doorknob yeah it's like a door knob
so he like when he [ __ ] when he when
he makes a left you're gonna tell him go
inside the house all right
lock the door
now for real his car the acceleration
it's on the
like on the bus it's like the the left
hand signal
it's just is this the what no that's the
blink man that's the blake
what the [ __ ] i picked him up a few
times when he was drunk i'm [ __ ]
talking i'm [ __ ] talking in morse
code over here
yeah i was up in stockton with fluffy
and
i'm in stockton hey stockton's in that
house yeah
you know it's funny because because i
was outside in stockton and i was
signing some autographs and uh
i got felt up by a lesbian
she started grabbing my cheeses and [ __ ]
and i'm thinking i'm thinking to myself
god damn it i look like a [ __ ]
lesbian
do you
yeah but up north yeah it was it was
cool it was cool
stockton was cool we went to chucks
chucks they're chucks yeah they got
pancakes the size of your head
how big are they man they don't even fit
on the plate they're called pancake
nipples and [ __ ] well they look
no they look like like kind of like a
shrimp cocktail effect like on shoes you
ever see the shoes on women's shoes
and and the the claws are hanging over
pups is dying over here
he looks like he's got a rocket ship to
the moon dawg
what the hell happened what's going on
little brother somebody called hold on
somebody called
for sure man it's a mating call
for you listeners man pops is having a
a laugh attack
happens at deja vu once a month eh no a
funny story he wants to
he took me on my birthday he took me to
a strip club right
the minute i walked into the street like
it goes dad i'm gonna take you it's like
you know i've never been here
and and we walk in and one of the
stripper sees and goes
crazy man you're here again
he know how to make it rain
crazy man i went broke that day
no it's funny because my wife thought he
was kidding at one time
the phone the phone the phone butt dial
the house right my wife answered hello
and she she hears this the stripper
talking to the bouncer saying
i'm gonna hold this phone so it brings
my [ __ ] money back
and my wife's like oh my god they
kidnapped them
gecko quick come here look what happened
what happened
no they kidnapped them he's probably had
a strip club he didn't have money to pay
and he's going to the atm they're
holding his phone
how the [ __ ] do you know this cause
that's crazy man
uh hilarious because he walks in all
nonchalant and so my wife's like
okay when you come i'm gonna get you he
walks in because
at that time he was going to to jc you
know college with her
at yeah junior college jc
and he walks in right he walks in on
enchilada quiet with
where were you studying you know how
moms are on the north carolina where
were you
going a little leg shaking like on that
novice
and starts dancing on the broom it
starts spinning on the broom
he has never been back to a strip club
again no mom no
so what's up fool
all right man we're going to have a yeah
man contest
yeah man the best young man contest
anyway anyways man people ask bro how we
came up with
it was yeah man and like does it really
rodrigo really say it but
can you tell the audience how did we
come up with yeah man yeah but i'm
toastmaster
he's actually a comedian you guys may
have seen him remember
he kind of talks about that
his name is rick gutierrez very funny
guy but he tours with gabriel and
he's a funny guy but but that's all yeah
man and everybody just got
got that like then we this guy nicknamed
them
chumps and nobody told him to his face
one day
we've been saying it for years dog
you guys have ugly ass friends
and they have nicknames but they never
heard that nickname and [ __ ] like
yeah hey bro where's cujo
the windows and stuff don't they look
like the projects
looks like william beat housing projects
man that one has bedbugs
you've been downtown reminiscing while
you're here i got one question why is
dog town right next to chinatown
just wondering
all right people we're gonna pick up
three people for the yeah man contest
yeah man
you wanna come up here and do it let me
know all right you can do it here
a guy a guy a girl you got all scared
huh three
talking all that [ __ ] in the dark we're
gonna win a contest
all right all right
felipe hey this guy right here right
here man
lisa raise your hand
all right come on is it looking like her
yeah man and you picked the winner
where do you want him here man here we
go
give him a microphone face down with the
word this is going live man we're going
to be on telemundo hello
we're going to be on mtv here we go the
platanito
watch out man [ __ ] we got some isis
looking mexicans
save me a taco dog or you feel like a
mosque flying to the lights
all right so we're going to start right
here your name mario
mario mario where you're from mario kart
long beach martini
lbc anybody else anybody else here from
long beach and compton anybody here
cause there's tacos in that area he
needs a ride home
compton has good taco bro they had a
bucket full of beans
all right you guys ready yeah yeah yeah
all right this is a good show right
of course you're supposed
you're right here bro get rid of them
this one's been getting ready for months
breaker all right your name caesar
caesar all right let's use it from where
uh paramount
paramount right everybody else paramount
in the house paramount 9021 all right
they have a lot of indoor
good bro what's your name coca-cola jack
jack
john jack chuck chuck chuck
jack jack j-o-m john you go home
john man you go home
[ __ ]
i have no idea what the hell is yeah man
he oh oh he's gonna win man that's a
real young man
is he a bird nest dog
show the hairs on the cheeks though
look all right
yeah man all right is this is this all
natural here no
that's just velcro supposed to say
man it's called huge come on
the guy that went first the first one
all right we're gonna go
thank you thank you thank you juan john
hey bro you like kids
all right one that's right yeah give us
a yeah man your man
yeah man he was a yeah man come on
what are you on heroin for one
all right bro you win the first prep bro
you went down sean the destroyer lafleur
signed
[ __ ] ufc gloves yeah man
second place isis
you want to sign [ __ ] glove by rocky
come on
leo santa cruz signed it bro he's
pretending by
rocky dick what else come
he's undefeated to him third place third
place
yeah man all right go for a day thank
you very much
eh thank you very much guys
bro got some cushioning on manuel all
right hell yeah bro that's gonna be hard
to jerk off man
you're gonna do the rock lobster
all right people you're ready or what
hell yeah
it's just the worry man the [ __ ]
rasta one though oh [ __ ] now
[ __ ] run from burbank left eh
ron from burbank are you gonna stay
mondo you can stay pops
yeah just stay right here bro let me do
a pumps walk away
walk away park give it up for pubs
a round of applause for my brother pop
scorcio let him hear it
see you later fool
all right bro thank you bro
oh yeah chilling
[ __ ] bro first ever live podcast the
group of fools huh
it's [ __ ] chaotic when there's people
around me it's a trip dog
you're gonna keep going and [ __ ] voices
everywhere though it's not like when we
do the live
podcast and it's like two hours we cut
it down to an hour and [ __ ]
you guys don't know man we're doing it
live or something like [ __ ] and
a lot of a lot of this
a lot of what you want to talk about bro
i don't know man this weed wore off
yeah man i was invited but i turned it
down man
i said nah man i ain't about i'm gonna
be on that show man and everybody does
mexican jokes in my favor [ __ ] that [ __ ]
i said hell nah i'm gonna do my own road
stay i'm gonna roast my mom man
imagine if they roast your mom yeah
remember this [ __ ] hit me at schoolway
this [ __ ] right here
over there that's where the mexican is
with a knuckle in the head
in church
she messed him up don't give a [ __ ] i
don't [ __ ] slap you in the [ __ ]
your quinceanera
everybody knows your 17th of the night
nothing went liz you got ready people
for our last guest
pasadena are you ready who likes heavy
metal
ladies and gentlemen one of the baddest
guitar players on the planet please put
your hands together
for bird breaks on mr singh kidding
everybody let him hear it
guitar player for ministry let him hear
it
let him hear it our brother yeah
what's up what's up brother how you
doing tim hell yeah bro we're right here
people
[ __ ] yeah man [ __ ] rock stars right
here now there's there's no heavy metals
here tonight right but you know what i'm
from boyle heights
yes all right any ministry fans here
they're over here hell yeah oh [ __ ]
rupees over there
[ __ ] comedians we don't get groupies
here our group is our guys
you know we do a comment you do a
comment you do a [ __ ] rock and roll
show bro
the [ __ ] titties waiting for you i do
a comedy show
it's a big fat dude when i hit a ball
and i'm like all righty
nobody has ever flashed their tits at me
and go you're funny
it's always like um i gotta do that i'll
give you five bucks just show them real
quick
only one time man i signed this lady's
boobs
and i actually like i don't want to i
don't know she just pulled them out
right
where do i sign and she had like a lot
of stretch marks on her boob
and she was funny she said just just
sign on a dotted line
you're like which one i don't know
it's like a mead 20 braille
what's up man how you been man from
touring i just got back yeah we were in
uh
australia and uh south america and
mexico
australia yeah played mexico city for
the first time which was a big deal for
me it was
unbelievable it was amazing man you know
it was a dream for me because my parents
are from mexico and
i never got to play there so that was my
first time so it was it was pretty
awesome
yeah i seen that footage you had on
facebook yeah yeah
hell yeah that wasn't me
yeah yeah every pretty much every gig i
think we did was sold out
what's it like man living the life of
the rock star man uh
it's pretty awesome not gonna lie
nah it's cool man you know i it's uh
something i wanted to do since i was a
little kid
ever since i got my first guitar at the
santa fe spring
swap meet the midnighters
yeah see you guys didn't think you guys
didn't think i was old school i am
um yeah i got my first guitar there and
uh started playing at like 10 years old
and um you know it's been uh it's been a
great ride man
all the way to pioneer chicken oh anyway
people
love you i gotta tell you i got my
girlfriend into pioneer chicken
and uh she's from uh she's from the east
coast and uh
now she's all addicted to pioneer
chicken like me i used to my mother one
time man i [ __ ]
i was so [ __ ] hungry man and i bit
and i [ __ ] bit into a hot ass pioneer
chicken breast
and the [ __ ] manteca oil from the
breast burned my throat all the way to
the bottom
like i bit the [ __ ] chicken breast
and all the oil came out
and like it just like shot in my mouth i
load down my throat like somebody coming
hey now
it's like somebody ejaculating hot oil
in my mouth
and i was like that was coffee
that happened to me last last sunday we
were there the chick is good and [ __ ]
yeah dude i was bummed i wanted to see
i wanted to see joey diaz man that's
right cocksucker's with me right now
i was bummed he's not here
i wanted to talk [ __ ] about the uh the
vegan
ceviche vegan ceviche i'm vegan yeah
what's up over here next time you guys
doing all right
we have a big ass troll over there bro
what's up bro i haven't heard a piece
though
i haven't seen you so you knocked that
dude out bro
tonight opening day for stepping on your
cortex
so what man so yeah man what you been up
to just got back from tour we go back
out in
three weeks peter the same question i'm
sorry man
are you stoned i was earlier
and i was sober but i'm just it's just
that you know man when you see a rock
star man you're just like [ __ ]
we're just in awe dawg you're right
there bro no bro you [ __ ] took
arsey's chick dog
or somebody's chick what are you saying
probably
something like you said you no no no you
were at a party one time and there was
you took these two chicks from somebody
and then g simmons told you good job
babe yeah yeah
it's true
that's that's that's uh many many years
ago
yeah way before i met my lovely
girlfriend here never mind that guy over
there he part of another band called the
instigator
they're uh they're opening up for us on
this next tour dude
you got a secret admirer yeah the
instigator they have they have hit songs
and their biggest hit is oh you better
do something
oh and followed by the the follow-up
here don't don't let yourself
push me again
so people a lot of people here don't
know man that um
everybody want for growing up man how
many people think that every
rock star gets [ __ ] up [ __ ] does coke
and heroin
those are the ones who don't make it man
those are the ones you see
playing at the hop
[ __ ] 70 years old playing at a
[ __ ] raspberry farm
club still playing the backyard parties
in west covina dude
i'm just
yeah right the instigators it's true
story
yeah i've never drank never smoked never
done any drugs what is that like
no cuz most of us here like this guy
right here is a beast like me man [ __ ] i
will do coke somebody holds my hair
man but to live a rock and roll
lifestyle
and run into big time rock stars and
never touch it like
like there's a pile of sugar right here
man even though i don't do coke no more
every once in a while make little lines
you know
of sugar all the time
how do you avoid that because you have a
very
a very strong i don't know what it is
strong personality
strong presence strong presence your
father said
yeah that had a lot to do with it but
right bro they're for you
i'm not really a cholo just backup
mapping
yeah it was i mean um i don't know i
wasn't i was never curious about that
i was uh preoccupied with other things
oh there goddamn [ __ ] flame over
there
want us to call an ambulance doctor what
dude i'm bummed out that homeboy split
dude
i was digging what's his name what's up
he had to go off he had to go up
he had to go put put away the um
carnival down the street
a little ferris wheel
that was cool man i like how he started
out
like he wasn't saying a word and then by
the end he was in the show oh yeah yeah
yeah
that [ __ ] 400 at the end yeah i did
yeah he's booking a gig here next month
dude his one-man show he started
he's starting his own podcast
ron and birdman show
so you grew up in east los angeles yeah
boy i'm off of
uh boylston street boylston but i know
where that is
yeah born over at the county usc man
this is what happened to
so you grew up right there right right
there by um by downtown lake boyle
yep temple yep right there food i used
to live right that little liquor
remember the little liquor store
right there there's a bakery right there
and the guy from the neighborhood
right there man every time like i would
go on a break to just stand there mad
dog and everybody gave me yeah
that was my that was my theo
yeah man i was living there dude how
[ __ ] crazy the neighborhood was bro i
was so cracked out
one of the homies sold me a stolen car
bro
for five hundred dollars damn and he had
the pink slip and everything
i found it in the glove boxing and then
i went up this and i saw the ignition
was broken and i said wow
that's weird
this [ __ ] so sold me a stolen
car for 500.
i only paid him 300.
and i told the other 200 in a week
and this who calls me up hey homie i'm
gonna want that 200 right now
bro oh ross you know what's gonna happen
now [ __ ] scared and [ __ ] and i paid
for 200
i you know and i'm stupid you know
because i still drove the stolen car for
a week
i want to get my 500 worth
damn i'm surprised i didn't run into you
in those
that neighborhood well there was a
penalty bro look at all that [ __ ]
nightmare on mentor street here
it's like uh it's like uh american me
extra
i know bro look at my [ __ ] freddy
cougar hipster over here
this [ __ ] haunts you during naps
you wake up you're eh
everyone had a good time so what's next
were you going to be at night my buddy
oh we uh us tour starts in four weeks
and um we're doing we're not doing la
we're doing anaheim we're doing the
grove
and um and we do canada and we go to uh
rio
in um september and i think that's it
for this year let's go man let's go have
you guys open the show
[ __ ] i'll be nuts dogs
then you'll have groupies i'll be like a
fat ass roadie bro waiting for church
but i'm with a band everybody was a band
literally what can i do to get in back
there what can't you do
you tell me i could have been a roadie
man but i'm [ __ ] lazy man
pick up those cables for
later though
like they were you were at work for your
daddy man you're like [ __ ]
your [ __ ] oh yeah of course i did a
mexican boy
my dad used to wake us up on saturday
morning to watch the truck man
and it was [ __ ] cold it wasn't it
wasn't even your truck
it wasn't even actually going nowhere
man
i'm at freezing watching my dad's truck
at seven in the morning but
just to go to church and then we didn't
take the truck
did that have one of those um chevrolets
with a camper and [ __ ]
we we did have a truck i don't know if
it was if it was that or not but we had
a truck with a camper
man we have a truck we had a truck with
a camper
but the inside of it was still metal oh
yeah
yeah yeah yeah we will get in there and
my dad would drive fast man
drunk driving and we're gonna start like
maracas yeah yeah
i got home and [ __ ] with a [ __ ]
[ __ ] up kneecaps
no seatbelts no remember old school days
you could ride in the back of those
things i mean i don't know if you could
or not but we did
hold on we did yeah you just hold on to
the sides before that before man
there was no camper you could just
[ __ ] hold on to the tree go to the
beach
it was [ __ ] up in mexico when we got
there we saw some guys riding on the
hood of a truck
like just laying on the hood of a work
truck and they were
whizzing down the freeway like that
it was but it was like it was like a
semi so like you know the windshield's
like this
those guys were hanging on with their
nails dude
it was it was really weird to see man
like doing like
65 down the freeway
yeah i thought we had a bad growing up
from the train the windshield wiper dog
he saw a windshield wiper
and instead of this bicep buying a new
windshield wiper
he just wrapped [ __ ] like um hospital
pants around in his shoes he put the
blue paper towel over that [ __ ]
ghetto get towed but it works
it works [ __ ] sucker and it wasn't even
raining it wasn't even raining
anything else nothing just uh if you
guys uh just let you know april 11th uh
stage two um right here at the ice house
i'll be there with the homies armando
gracie and pops
special guest uh jay london did
everybody follow the [ __ ]
already
everybody follow him everybody leave a
comment
all right unfollow the [ __ ]
man this is your baby what you do
[ __ ] mexican albino [ __ ]
right here
anyway he's a good guy man
he tries
oh man we got bunion stories left man
so ladies and gentlemen a big help for
st thank you very much
let him hear it laying it down like your
brother always man
he's been coming to the show since 2010
people big fan [ __ ] rock star
all around cool [ __ ] dog it was
cool man imagine if i stretch it on my
hair man
like [ __ ] interview with a fat
vampire
yeah blood is like gravy for me
yeah man we did it my first live podcast
thank you everybody for coming out
on the world thank you very much what's
up full podcast
all things comedy network
thank you very much for coming out